[SOUND] Oh, good,
you made it to the end.
Or did you take some longest, shortest
path through the lesson to get here?
Well, here's what I think are the two
big ideas of this lesson.
The first one is the [COUGH] excuse me,
[COUGH] the first one is
the idea of congestion.
[SOUND]
>> Boo.
>> This concept let's you design for
one topology and
then estimate whether it will
map well or poorly to another.
The second big idea is to exploit
higher dimensional networks,
both for fun and for profit.
For instance,
you should have noticed that there are
big algorithmic scalability wins from
taking advantage of a 3D mesh
network instead of a 2D one.
Now, in closing,
let me pose one last question.
As systems get bigger,
will topology matter again?
If it does, you will be ready.